this is interior angles that subheading
so what might you guess the second
subheading is exterior the opposite of
interior so
exterior now for this next bit what I
want you to do is just put your pens
down
I won't rub this off so it well it won't
disappear you can copy it down a second
I just need to you know watch this
because it's a little bit weird okay
exterior angles mean the angles on the
outside of the shape but you do it in a
particular way so what I'm gonna do is
let me draw redraw this garnet because
it's a bit easier to replicate okay now
watch this part carefully because I
remember when I was in year 10 quite
confused by this because you can do it
wrong okay what I'm going to do is I'm
going to extend each of the sides but
I'm gonna extend them all in the same
direction generally you'd pick either
clockwise or anti-clockwise but it's
important you go the same all the way
around so for instance which would you
like clockwise anti-clockwise clockwise
plain so I'm gonna go with this one
right the clockwise direction is this
way you see that I'm going round that
way okay so I'm going to extend this
side in the clockwise direction like so
that make sense
wait sorry you mean say to the right is
that what you mean ah okay because that
direction I can't say to the right it's
gonna be left and down and it's gonna
change as I go around so clockwise stays
the same though I did this side done now
I do this one I'm going clockwise after
all so it's going to go down this way
you see it's gonna go that way
okay so I've gone in the same clockwise
direction so this one's done clockwise
for this side is to the left right so it
goes this way then this way and my last
one is that one okay oh because what I'm
doing is I'm extending a side so I'm not
going to go off in a different direction
I'm gonna go in the same direction as
the side which is why you've you've
extent you've made all those longer
basically okay now here's the important
bit again keep watching keep watching
each line I've created has an angle on
both sides it's got an angle on both now
have a look at for example this the
first one I drew see this angle
you what's that that's 1/8 it's a
straight line I'm not interested in that
one I'm interested in this one okay I'm
just gonna call that we use Greek
letters we've seen this before I'm gonna
call this guy alpha okay
I'm gonna keep going around clockwise
this guy here the one that's not just
180 I'm gonna call that one beat up that
leaves me with gamma that would be I'll
show you how to draw it that's a delta
and this one in here is what am i onto
oh this is a fun one
this is Epsilon okay so there's five
sides there's five angles but they're
not inside the polygons they're outside
which is why they're exterior angles
here's the weird thing
you know how I'm interior angles the
bigger your polygon is the bigger your
angle some would be right you know a lot
of you are carrying a dodecagon in your
pockets which is uh in Australia what's
the most famous dodecagon it's a 50-cent
coin thank you very much because of this
you guys can tell me the angle some of
that dodecagon it would be 12 minus 2 10
times right so 1800 degrees more sides
means a bigger angle but the weird thing
with this is and you can write this down
now okay the exterior angle psalm the
exterior angle some of every polygon
ever everywhere is always every time the
same number it's always 360 hmm now
that's a bit weird that's a bit
counterintuitive I can prove this for
you but it's a bit mind-bending and I
want to let it sit first before I am
before I explain it to you so I might
reserve that for our next lesson I just
want to show you the result you can use
it before you understand it and then
once you're a little more comfortable
with it I will show you how it happens
okay so I want you to write down first
interior exterior okay please take care
like I said in how you draw how you
extend those sides because I used to
like it
one in one direction and then I'd go the
other one in a different direction I
wouldn't go clockwise all the way I'd go
clockwise and then Midway I'd forget
which way I was going and I'd go
anti-clockwise for one and it's a
different bunch of angles so just watch
out all on the same direction every
single one 360